autre ouvrage qui risque lui aussi de
faire parler de lui
le vrai pouvoir d'un lobby de thierry
costes ce livre lève le voile sur
l'influencé des lobbys en france ces
groupes de pression qui existe dans le
domaine politique économique ou sportifs
son auteur à thierry costes et
franc-comtois et il est sur ce plateau
bonsoir le vrai pouvoir d'un lobby ou en
fait comment vous nous sommes manipulés
à la suite de notre plein gré pour
reprendre une formule bien connue c'est
ça que relève votre fils votre livre
pardon oui j'ai voulu un peu démystifier
le lobbying alors je crois quand le
démystifiant j'ai un peut aggraver mon
cas
parce que je parle beaucoup d'espionnage
de manipulation et mais je pense qu'en
france on a un problème avec le lobbing
donc il est toujours sulfureux alors que
dans la réalité à bruxelles dans les
autres pays européens
le bing est beaucoup plus simple est
peut-être moins dangereux pour la
démocratie
en tout cas les exemples de lobbing les
plus flagrants c'est celui c'est ce qui
a dans le monde politique et humaine
vous avez dû avoir à faire à nos hommes
politiques ou à nos femmes politiques de
la région quelle relation vous avez avec
eux ou avec elle
avec dominique voynet mais qui n'est
plus dans la région depuis peu ça s'est
très mal passé parce que j'ai beaucoup
défendu des industriels qui s'occupent
d'environnement mais dans une logique
industrielle et ça comme il était
ministre de l'écologie et patronne des
verts
ça s'est relativement mal passé
chevènement s'était mieux il faut dire
que vous vous occupez des dossiers
plutôt polémique non oui j'adore les
dossiers polémiques que ce soit la
chasse les dossiers toxiques les délais
nucléaire ou l'amiante doc c'est clair
oui mais le bing c'est ça c'est
s'occuper des dossiers qui fâchent et
c'est le principe du lobbying c'est de
faire changer d'avis les hommes
politiques les hommes ou les femmes
politiques
alors vous êtes un lobbying à l'aube
hingst c'est difficile à dire
professionnel vous avez créé d'ailleurs
un cabinet de lobbying
vous êtes en fait un professionnel de l'
influence on peut même dire un pro de la
mine peu de manipulation en quelque
sorte c'est pas géré en gênant comme
comme terme pour vous un pro de la
manipulation
non pas du tout je l'assumé pleinement
ce que je pense que le lobbying peut
être très utile à la démocratie parce
que souvent je pense que le plus
dangereux
c'est l'entourage des hommes politiques
essaient parfois les hommes politiques
eux mêmes qu'ils n'écoutent pas qu'ils
n'écoutent pas le monde économique moi
je défends le monde économique
alors c'est sûr que j'utilise toutes les
méthodes mais parce que le lobbying
c'est très large regardez jean lassalle
qui a fait une grève de la faim
le député c'est une action d' influence
la preuve il a fait changer d'avis le
gouvernement ait un industriel
c'est un sujet en effet passionnant pour
qu'on parlait pendant quelques heures on
pourrait même parler du lobbying des
médias mais on n'a pas le temps
puisqu'elle étudiants aussi leurs
limites au niveau du temps le vrai
pouvoir d'un lobby c'est votre premier
ouvrage est donc c'est passionnant comme
j'aime le dire et on le retrouve dans
toutes les bonnes librairies
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
[Musique]